the hearing  for the new supreme court justice  katanji brown jackson is happening and  there was just an extraordinary moment  and she's sort of the perfect  she's the perfect bite nominee  can you provide a definition for the  word woman  can i provide a definition no yeah  i can't  you can't  not okay this context i'm not a biology  of the word woman is so unclear and  controversial that you can't give me a  definition  senator in my work as a judge what i do  is i  address disputes if there's a dispute  about a definition people make arguments  and i look at the law and i decide so  i'm not  the fact that you  can't give me a straight answer about  something as fundamental as what a woman  is underscores the dangers of the kind  of progressive education  that we are hearing about